did your parents i know that your
parents i believe got
vaccinated mine got vaccinated last week
and yours got vaccinated as well
yes my mom is actually i talked to her
today she's getting her
second shot uh if not tomorrow the
following day yeah
right so she's i'm very excited about it
she's happy about it
and my dad he gets his next shot i think
the following week whatever so uh you
know anything that can
get her back in the casinos she'll she's
she's going to be happy
she likes to give her people the church
that says her her two things are she
likes to go to the casino
and she likes church she can find a
church
with some slot machines
i hope that for her you know um it's
also important to get the message out i
know that in the african-american
community
there is rightly some suspicion
about the vaccine when i say rightly i
mean historically
there's a good reason why uh black
people
uh are wary of a government-endorsed
vaccine but
we want to get the word out that i i
think uh of all the people that have
been vaccinated so far i think
sixty percent are white and only five
percent
are are black and we want to make sure
that people
in in that community know that these
vaccines are safe
and they need to go out when it's their
turn and get a vac get vaccinated
absolutely my parents are in their 80s
the first
uh shot they had no problems with and
they're
you know very excited to get the to get
the second one
yeah um yeah it's safe and i mean
we are it's killing us it's our
communities are
uh being the most affected by it so we
yeah
got to get this vaccine okay i'm glad
i'm glad you're
getting that word out there and i'm glad
your folks are doing well